you
so today i wanted to talk a little bit
about the future computing i think
that's kind of in tradition with jay s
comp and kind of talking about the
present and the future but i wanted to
start today by looking at where we've
been so in computing you know computing
started as a computer was something that
took up a whole room it was something
that only a government had access to
this is a this is an N evac it was a
computer that was developed in the
United States ran on vacuum tubes that's
what all those little those little all
those little knobs are and essentially
people ran around in suits changing
vacuum tubes frantically while wow this
computer started to compute or try to
compute something for us and so this is
very inaccessible to obviously the
average person and you know over the
next 10 years the computers became
accessible to people in in large
corporations they became accessible to
people in universities this is what am I
actually one of my favorite pictures in
computing this is a PDP 11 which is a if
any of you actually studied that in
university but it's a fantastic
architecture for its time and this is
Kernighan and richie at Bell Labs one of
my favorite research institutions and
always like to imagine it they're
inventing the C programming language but
this computer is a thousand times faster
than the previous one so thousands times
cheaper it's now accessible to two more
people and this trajectory increase i
think you know from here people know
kind of the story things computers got
less less expensive they got even more
powerful people at companies had access
to computers and then they are able to
start having them in their homes they
started you know these computers became
more mobile they came even even cheaper
until they came to the point where we
basically always have a computer in our
pocket and so computers now are
ubiquitous in our lives and it's you
know it's possible that one of these
things we start you know that we think
about what's next in computing and i
think because the mobile phone is is the
the current state of the art we start
thinking about what's next it's possible
that something like a watch or something
like a pair of glasses are really the
next thing but i really believe it's
next things that are going to be big and
computing are the things that are
already in our lives the everyday things
that are already in our lives so you
know
light switches electrical sockets
doorbells stop lights these are the
things that are I think that computing
is going to go to next and is really
good where a lot of change in our lives
are going to is going to occur and one
of the things that is driving this trend
this is the emergence of open and very
very inexpensive hardware so this is for
people that don't recognize it on site
this is what's called a raspberry pi
this is ben 445 US dollars it's a fully
featured computer it can run a full OS
it has hdmi out yes USB port has
everything and and more importantly and
so this this device is built for
emerging mark or emerging countries in
particular Africa and beyond that
couldn't afford a very expensive
computer so folks would hook this up to
their television set and plug in a
keyboard via USB and it's been really
successful in that sense a way that it's
being used that it was never know that
people did never imagined is that it's
being hooked up to every day saying so
these little pins along the edge there
are actually Jen what's called a
general-purpose eye open and that allows
you to hook it up to everyday things so
things that have analog values you know
voltages that that vary as opposed to
just digital ones and zeros and this has
led to an explosion of different types
of hardware and some of which are really
important I think for us is JavaScript
developers this is what's called a
tehsil this is a Kickstarter project
that a group of folks at MIT are working
on this runs JavaScript natively on a
betel piece of hardware it actually
compiles it to lua on the Lua vm and
runs it but you can hook in all these
little connectors you can hook in
additional things temperature sensors
Bluetooth connectors all sorts of things
that allow you to interface it with the
physical world and it's not alone
there's no there's another Kickstarter
project that's even more interesting in
my perspective called espera know which
is a completely open hardware design
that runs JavaScript natively and what's
really interesting about this is it's is
you could take this
add it to your hardware add it to your
projects even either in a personal sense
or in a professional sense and build
things that build upon this platform and
so you know the the the the trend I'm
trying to lead you here is that is that
this hardware is becoming much more
accessible and even the enclosure so
when you start thinking about you need
to enclose these product you know if you
want to use them in the real world
typically you need to enclose them in
plastic or something like that even the
way you design these these physical
enclosures is becoming software i
actually just discovered this program
this week it's called open s cad and
essentially what this is is it's a
programming language for building 3d
models so i want to build here i'm
building an enclosure for the Raspberry
Pi that i showed earlier and if you
lotus little to the left you have a
programming language that almost looks
like javascript and basically what it
allows you to do is to express the the
3d model that you want to build and so
here it's a little small and hard to
read but basically i'm taking two cubes
and I'm differencing them and that's
producing this kind of this this box
like enclosure that I'm going to use for
my raspberry pi so this is not obviously
not completed I just started on this
this week but you know the thing to
notice is that everything is becoming
much more it is being driven by software
and so in my opinion software is is is
is eating hardware this is an apple one
and so in when they built the apple on
the Apple one is the very first computer
that Apple made the software on this was
really more like hardware all those
chips along there that that Steve
Wozniak he basically designed the
program by putting different chips on
the board and you know you contrast that
to the previous slide where everything
was basically specified with software
you can see the arc of where we're going
wherever you know where computers used
to be you know literally pieces of
hardware that you glued together and
where you know we have the term bug
because actual moth flew into a computer
and caused a short between one of these
these electrical circuits the trajectory
is that if you start thinking about five
years out everything is going to be
software and I think a project that I
saw that kind of kind of
takes this glues this all together is is
a project that i saw on kickstarter
called the good night light and i think
this is a really interesting example is
because it's taken something is really
simple it's a light and it's only light
and it's made it really interesting
using the the things that I've just
talked about the computation and
connectivity so this light is you buy
them in a pair and it has it has a twist
and so in that you could maybe a little
bit hard to tell but on the top of this
this light there's a little chimney and
that's the button for the light and what
you do is you give one of these lights
to one of your loved ones and when you
push the chim your chimney it doesn't
turn on your life but it actually turns
out in their light in their house and so
this is a way that you can tell somebody
over a distance that you're thinking
about them and you know or you know or
whatever and I think this is really is
this really cool it's taken something
it's very simple it has a real-world
user interface and it's made it better
with computing and I think this is the
kind of shape of what computing is going
to look like in the future where you
interact with things in the ways of your
you know you're used to used to doing
and computing is completely behind the
scenes and just makes it happen the way
that you expect so you know as mentioned
in both of my intros I worked for a
company I called nest labs so nest labs
is building a thermostat thermostat you
know I used to guys obviously have
air-conditioning here but allows you to
you know to control the temperature in
your house and what this did is it
dynamically detected what temperatures
you liked at what times it could detect
if you walk past the thermostat and
automatically turn itself off and save
energy for the house and save you money
but when I you know then working on that
I learned know that that when you go to
do this for real it's really difficult
so the Internet of Things is very
difficult there's a number of problems
that you actually have to solve before
you can even get started and the reason
for this is that these these real things
in our lives are actually really
dangerous if they fall into the wrong
hands so if you think about the previous
example of a thermostat if somebody has
access to that and I actually come from
a very cold place and United State
it's in Michigan in the very north you
know where it can drop to negative 10
Celsius if a hacker gets access to that
and turns it turns basically turns off
my heater people you know it has
life-threatening consequences and so
when you start building real-world
products like this you need to think
about these things up front so how do
how does this device Afeni Kate who has
access or you know who has authorization
to use a device like this and then how
do these devices communicate with
applications so I thought I would you
know I there's you know there's a number
of models about how this would you know
how this potentially work but I thought
I would talk about that you know
controlling a light as one example and
one of the major ways that people are
talking about solving this problem is
through a messaging approach because
these devices aren't always connected
they for power reasons for connectivity
reasons you can't always assume that
they're connected at all time and so a
messaging approach works really well for
this and so you know you could think
about this and as in terms of its
sending commands to the light and
settings which you know responses back
from that so in this case I'm using
what's called a switch command to turn
on the light the light responds and says
okay I got you I got your I got you know
I got your command I've turned on the
light and and now it's on oh got a stray
arrow there sorry um I'm actually not at
the expert at powerpoint now I'm running
at keynote so who knows so what's
interesting about this if you start
thinking about that message stream is
that you you can start mining that
message stream to build really
interesting applications and so here I'm
diagrammed out how you might use
something like this to build a vacation
application so let's say you wanted your
life to go on and off automatically you
know while you're on vacation or not
while you're on vacation you could look
at when when you were normally turning
it on and then just basically replicate
that and so if you start using this
messaging model or think about it it's
kind of Twitter for devices this is the
kind of applications at these that this
enables and so I've been working with a
number of companies so as he mentioned i
worked with the microsoft accelerators
around the world so I working with a
number of companies to
to help them do you know launch their
products on Windows Azure and on Windows
platforms in general and one of the one
of the companies that I'm working with
is actually trying to add these types of
smarts to everyday items inside the
house n another one has a much more
industrial application for this inside
factory floors and you know as part of
working with them and when I experienced
in working at nest there's I realize
that there's always common set of
problems that are hard for people to get
right and so I started a project called
nitrogen and you know thanks to jay asia
for letting me talk about it but
essentially it's a platform that solves
all these hard problems for you so you
can focus on on your device on your
application and not have to solve this
you know reinvent the wheel so to speak
it's written completely the end to end
in JavaScript and that builds on my
belief that in the long term that
JavaScript given its ubiquity in the
computing industry is going to eat all
of software and so it's built I think I
mentioned in ojs and then the client
there's there's there's JavaScript
clients available as a node module then
also in the browser and I thought you
know that you know the best way to kind
of walk through it would be to do to
show an example and so what I've done
here is I'm going to I'm going to show
an example of how you would build the
internet connected camera using using
nitrogen so this is a Raspberry Pi again
the Raspberry Pi has a module you can
buy to add on that hooks in and it's a
camera so that's the camera connected
with a lead to the Raspberry Pi and so I
put this in an enclosure and I put it in
the front window of my house and one in
my garage and I've connected it using
nitrogen so I'm going to switch over
hopefully the github and show you the
code for this looks like so another
thing is all this code to all the code
that I nitrogen and all the sample code
that I've written is all apache2 license
so you're welcome to use it in your
projects to use it in at home for fun or
or whatnot and so what you know my gosh
that's small
that's right that better okay and so
this is an example of a device
application so this is running on the
Raspberry Pi running as a node
application and it's simple and that's
and that's really the you know the goal
of it right so there's really only one
there's really only one line attention
here so i have a configuration section
where i define all the cameras that i
have and then essentially i do a service
connect and this heavy handles all that
heavy lifting that we're talking about
that kind of you know list of pain that
we have when you start doing Internet of
Things projects it does all the
authorization or the afen occation and
all the authorization and it returns a
session that we can use for subsequent
things and then I also you know start a
new the i start a new a camera manager
and the manager inside nitrogen
essentially follows that that stream of
that the kind of Twitter stream of
messages for the camera and reacts to
command messages that are sent to it so
in this case I'm following all the all
the all the messages to and from this
this camera and reacting appropriately
and so one of the other things that I've
built as part of nitrogen is a really
simple kind of administrator should miss
no one more time that work one more time
nope not that many times all right so I
build a really simple admin tool and you
know what this allows you to do is see
how these devices are operating in your
you know in in the in the kind of the
network that you set up and so I'm going
to try here Wi-Fi willing and demo gods
willing to actually take a picture of I
have a picture of my garage and the
application that I'm thinking of here is
kind of using it as an alarm
unfortunately where I live in Santa Cruz
California there's a little bit of kind
of casual theft of bicycles so actually
right here I have a camera that's that's
in my garage looking at a set of
bicycles that we have and so it's dark
this makes me jet lag just looking at it
and I did that a little bit too fast but
I just did there as I issued
one of those those commands do that that
camera in my garage and it responded
back with an image and so you could see
I'll do one more ques up the snapshot
command sends it over to California
California camera takes a picture and
sends it back so that's the idea yeah
thank you thank goodness it works and so
that's the general idea right so you you
have you had these commands that are
your kind of well-defined with
well-defined schemas and then these
applications can use these commands to
to control things in the real world and
what's interesting about that is the
application knew nothing about the
device it doesn't know how that device
is implemented it doesn't know what kind
of camera it is it just knows that if it
issues a camera command that this this
camera can can answer to it and what's
interesting about that is you can start
building up really interesting
applications and so one of my art
projects is using the camera out the
front of my house I'm trying to take a
picture of a sunset every every day for
a full year and then I put it on a
poster or something so we'll see but you
know of course you know the note those
years have done note I you know the the
note ecosystem is amazing i thought i
was gonna have to write my own sunset
calculator no of course not there's
already an amazing package called Sun
calc that allows you to you know
calculate the sunset of any place on
earth thank you hopefully you're out
there and you hear my thanks so what
I've done is this is looks really
complicated but it's actually pretty
simple i calculate the the sunset time
for when the Sun is point three degrees
above the horizon because I don't want
to be down completely otherwise you know
it's not really interesting picture then
I just basically look to see if I have I
have any of these sunset commands
already and the real you know the real
meat of this is I essentially send it a
message and I say hey at the sunset this
sunset time just take a photo for me and
just and put it in and put it into this
devices feed and that's really it and so
why what I've been doing is is is is
essentially collecting these whoops oh
yeah so and so I ran this before so I
stacked up right here you can see these
are all
actually commands in the future and I've
stacked up all these so it's ready to
take sunset images and of course I've
thousand IP messages I knew that was
going to happen hang on hopefully there
we go whoops
whoops
here somewhere
but basically I just could have
collected a there we go there there some
of the sunshine shots I've collected a
ton of these different sunsets and you
can see now that we're in the winner
it's starting to be you know more cloudy
and whatnot and so I think that's you
know the idea is that these applications
don't have to know about the devices
they're using and you start building up
these really interesting feeds that then
different applications can use to build
you know interesting applications with
so let me switch back to this I don't
have much more but you know if you're
interested in this area you know I've
talked about this as and I'm sure your
your kind of thinking that you know this
is completely you know why do I need to
know anything about this but I would
challenge you to think back seven years
and how you thought about the mobile web
and you I think many of you if you think
back seven years you would never have
guessed that you know your day to day
job today you'd spend a predominant
amount of time thinking about mobile and
I actually think that it's gonna be very
similar for these everyday things I
think if you look out seven years I
think you know a lot of us will be doing
things that have a lot of impact I have
a lot to do with everyday things and
working with hardware so I would
challenge you even if you don't you're
not used to this but to actually do look
into it and start getting you know start
learning a little bit about these these
these different platforms and so I just
thought I'd talk to finish off by
talking about a couple things that I
want to do in the future with the
platform then I'm happy to take
questions the first is I you know the
current Internet of Things has a very
very centralized model so these devices
connect directly into a cloud service
and and communicate back and forth I
don't think this is the right approach
for two reasons the first is a very that
is a very high latency solution so you
know the previous presenter mentioned
you know making a trip out to all the
way out to you know potentially across
the country to a cloud service and back
and can you know be up to 400
milliseconds or 600 milliseconds and it
for a lot of applications that's too
that's too you know it's too much time
and the second thing is this gives up a
lot of our privacy so these are the
Internet of Things these everything when
computing it goes out to everything in
our lives sending back all this data to
a centralized place I think
is is really dangerous and so one of the
things that I'm working out as part of
this project is to figure out how we can
distribute this such that we have
control over how this data is sent up to
cloud services and so instead of sending
everything about our presence in our
house and no matter our likes and
dislikes and and all these types of
things up to a cloud service that a lot
of that data we actually reside in our
house and we would decide what we need
want to exchange that with an
application that may exist in the public
cloud another thing we need to think
about you know is that I'm thinking
about as this project is how you how you
keep these devices up-to-date I think as
we ant Lee demonstrated today with our
with our with with by a connectivity
woes we have a long way to go in terms
of making devices you know plug-and-play
completely plug and play this is an
extreme example this is actually a
climate sensor that's down in Antarctica
and I use an extreme example because you
know for somebody to do an upgrade of
this let you know assuming they didn't
have any connectivity you know they'd
have to take a snowmobile and I'd
probably and you know involved in a very
thick coat at the least to get out here
and so I think this is an extreme
example but as the number and we started
extending computing out to these devices
in our house and our intern our
businesses there's going to be too many
of them to manually manage them it's not
going to be okay to do an OS upgrade or
upgrade you know update all on mine your
applications like we do on our phone it
can't be that primitive it has to be
completely managed in a transparent
sense otherwise we're all going to go
insane even no matter how much we love
technology and so one of the things I'm
working on is being able to
transparently upgrade the applications
and the firmware and the things that run
on these devices and then also extending
it out to the smallest and the most
embedded the most very you know
lightweight not very much processing
power devices so that's all I have I
somehow managed to cut out my slide with
anyway with the links to this but go to
nitrogen do if you're interested it's
I'm building all of this in
and I'm taking JavaScript as far as I
can with this problem I think there's
going to some devices where we have to
use C++ but javascript I think could do
can go very deep into this into this
problem and if you're interested in
contributing I would love to I'd love to
have your help and yeah thanks for
letting me come and talk to my crazy
project Kim yeah got a question yeah one
of the devices that he mentioned you
said that the that the javascript is
being compiled down to lure yeah that's
why is that I think it's from a resource
perspective I didn't know I didn't
design that so I can't say for certain
but I think their idea was that the Lua
vm was a little bit more memory can
efficiently efficient oh yeah I don't
know why but that the that's that's the
tehsil the tehsil hardware and they're
very open folk so you can approach them
on the web and right nice thanks yeah i
think i could try to answer that a
little weight yeah essentially Lua from
the almost the very beginning has been
they've been trying to make it in such a
way that it really should be for
embedded applications and there isn't a
sort of a vm that has optimized for
embedded applications for javascript not
yet mm-hmm so it's the best way to go
right now it's compile it down to